[Music]
well hello dear friends welcome to our
program i'd like to know
this is a question and answer program
where you send us your questions
we do the research and in so far as it
is possible we answer the questions on
the air the program airs
every tuesday at 4 30 in the afternoon
pacific standard time
we're glad you decided to join us and
let me just announce the email address
where you can send us your questions
you can send them to tv
at some tv dot org once again tv at some
tv dot org i have here our associate
speaker
c.a murray
and
it's always good to work with him you
know i've had a couple of people tell me
uh recently that you know we just flow
very smoothly when we work together well
praise the lord
i thank the lord for that and one of the
people that tell me that fairly
consistency is my own sister who has a
critical eye
and does not lie
if she thinks something is not good she
will tell you so donna says that we work
well together and i agree we do we do i
enjoy being in your company i guess
honesty runs in the family amen and amen
okay do you want to have a word of
prayer and then we'll get into our
questions be glad to father god
how we thank you and praise you for the
study of your word we thank you that
this bible is alive and living and
breathing and that it breathes into us
your spirit and enables us and gives us
direction how to live our lives here and
how to prepare for that day when christ
shall come and put in his appearance we
pray and ask
that you would be the center in
circumference of all that we do this
afternoon
that you would be the teacher that the
words that we say would be but the
outworking of your will for us and for
your people and we thank you in advance
for your promise to hear and answer the
prayer of faith in jesus name amen amen
well this first question that we're
going to deal with is a page long so i'm
not going to read the questions i'm
going to synthesize the content of the
question indeed
basically the idea is that at seventh
day evidence we are historicists
we believe that the seven churches cover
church history in order we believe that
the seals cover the same period
with different details we believe the
trumpets also repeat history we believe
that daniel 7 has a sequence of events
in chronological order
so the question that this person asks is
why do you have some cases where you
have flashbacks and where the flow moves
forward and not strictly in the
chronological order in the sequence
you know like for example under the
sixth uh seal
you have uh
a past fulfillment of the sixth seal
which is the signs in the sun moon and
stars and then the same seal it takes
you forward all the way to the second
coming of christ the second part of the
sixth seal
when it comes to revelation 20 you have
four cycles in revelation 20 where
it goes full circle over the events
before during and after the millennium
so what can we say about
the issue of recapitulations and
foretastes and within the historicist
time frame
one of the things i would say because
you you dealt with some some of that
revelation 20 in our latest anchors
and did a fine job
um
the historic historicist historicist
methodology
is a methodology that we use
to understand scripture
it does not mean that every scripture is
going to follow one upon another and one
upon another with no breaks no uh you
know particularly in daniel russian they
they circle back on themselves and they
expand so uh historicist doesn't mean
that
the scripture
10 is going to always follow after 9
after 11. it means that you use that
methodology in trying to understand
scripture when you try to put everything
in the past when you try to put
everything in the future uh you run into
problems so the the historicist
methodology is what we use to understand
and interpret scripture yeah you know
let's take daniel 7 as an example
uh we know that daniel 7 has a lion a
bear a leopard a dragon beast the dragon
beast sprouts ten horns and then among
the ten horns comes a little horn
and then you have the second coming of
christ yes
but within the chapter you have four
cycles
because the aspect of the little horn is
come back to four times in the chapter
and so
even though you have a historic
historicist structure
of a sequence of events
there are recapitulations within the
sequence of events and that does not
destroy historicism no it's simply that
each
cycle repeats and amplifies what you had
in the first cycle
i think that that that's well said again
the the the historicist is just the
methodology you apply for interpretation
as opposed to a preterist or a futurist
you let the bible explain itself and you
walk through it in its historical
context but many times the bible of
course put down revelation repeat and
enlarge repeat and enlarge and when you
repeat it enlarge it may look like
you're you're going someplace or you're
not you're just giving further light or
increased light on something that you've
already spoken about right
so you know i wish we had lots of time
to answer fully every single question
you know we could spend several programs
just giving examples
of how you have a historicist sequence
but at the same time you have cycles
within the historical sequence of powers
recapitulations you know
adding information that was not in the
previous cycle etc yes but that does not
destroy the historic historicist
sequence of the fulfillment of
historical events very well said
okay the next question
has to do with first fruits
and this is what the question says i am
studying your presentation of the hebrew
religious calendar series
and i am confused about the group that
resurrected with jesus
this is my understanding so far for
those lessons
from your lesson about the first fruits
that lesson number nine i understood
that this group went with jesus on
resurrection mourning to be waived as
first fruits before the father at 9 00
am the 16th of nisan which would be
resurrected resurrection sunday
and then
you know there's another case
where
there's first firstfruits offered 40
days later on the day of pentecost
so the question
that this person is asks is
you know when were
those who resurrected with jesus
presented before the father was it on
resurrection morning
or was it 40 days later when jesus
ascended to heaven to begin his
intercessory work
so that's the big question that is the
big question indeed
now we we know
just as a start we know
that uh jesus
resurrected the first fruits
so we know that jesus went before the
father to fulfill the feast of the first
fruits the day of the resurrection
let's read first corinthians chapter 15
first corinthians 15 i'm there
ah you already have that good because
enough when i saw first fruits i said
let me go find some first fruits text
and see if we can dig in so i had this
there good uh go ahead and read it uh
we're at verse 20
but now christ is risen from the dead
and has become the first fruits of those
who have fallen asleep
for since by man came death
by man came also the resurrection of the
dead
okay so we know that jesus
uh presented himself before the lord on
resurrected mourning
probably at the door of the heavenly
sanctuary because the first fruits were
waved at the door at the door of the
sanctuary in the court yes uh so we know
that jesus at least ascended on
resurrection mourning to present himself
before his father
and then we also know that 40 days later
jesus of course ascended to heaven and
once again entered into the presence of
his father
and he had with him
those who resurrected with him yes
and it's interesting that on the day of
pentecost according to leviticus 23
there were also first fruits that were
offered
so not only do you have the first fruits
the day after unleavened bread but you
have the first fruits
40 days later
actually 50 days later on the day of
pentecost yes yes we talked about that
that ascension of christ to
heaven a
quick trip
some time ago answering another question
so it it follows the the biblical
parallel uh first fruits and then 50
days later 40 days later uh
another first fruits christ of course is
the first fruit but he took some
trophies back with him which are also
first fruits
yeah and that group of course is
mentioned in matthew 27 51-53
and some people say well do you have any
other references to the fact that these
people who resurrected with jesus
ascended to heaven with him and the
answer is yes
you know the famous passage in ephesians
chapter 4
where it says that
he led captivity captive yes and he gave
gifts to men
of course the gifts to men
is the gift of the holy spirit with all
of the gifts of the spirit yes
and he led captivity captive means that
he took those who were captive in the
tomb with him to heaven and then he gave
gifts to men well said
and that comes of course from psalm 68
which is the original root prophecy
for ephesians chapter 4 and i think
it's
verse 9
and following in ephesians yes
so anyway i hope that this helps
in our answer to this question
let's take another question
this one
is very interesting
it seemingly
has the intention of of presenting a
contradiction in the writings of ellen
white
so let's take a look at it
um
in 1898 ellen white had said that
christ's deity
suffered
and sank
under the agonies of calvary
that's uh seven bible commentary page
907 paragraph two
so this statement ellen white wrote that
christ's deity suffered and sank under
the agonies of calvary
but then she wrote uh in um
youth's instructor
august 4 1898 humanity died
divinity did not die
in his divinity christ possessed the
power to break the bonds of death then
manuscript 140 1903
she wrote the deity did not sink
under the agonizing torture of calvary
so
she says it sank
and she says it didn't sink
but the statement that brings everything
together
is letter 280 1904
where she wrote
when christ was crucified
it was his human nature that died
now here comes the key
deity did not sink and die
so when little white says that divinity
did not sink
what she's saying is that divinity did
not sink and die and die so that
statement completes her thought
about
the the deity of christ of course we
know the deity of christ could not die
because his deity is immortal
but the deity could sink
in the sense that in the garden of
gethsemane he felt forsaken by his
father
he could not see beyond the portals of
the tomb yes but
his divinity did not die and of course
he was he was keenly aware of the
the enmity uh of that god had against
sin and since he had become sin uh
uh and and she says that
you know the situation didn't really
these are my words not hers um
show him that he was going to come out
successful on the other side he was just
going in a relationship that he
established with his father um
how divinity and humanity were blended
in christ will be a study for the ages
so if we try to
dig into that too much we are really in
a speculative area because we just don't
know we'll be studying that for a long
time and we may never fully understand
it we can appreciate it and and glory in
it but we will not be able to dissect it
so uh suffice it to say the humanity of
christ which he had taken on four
thousand years of human degradation uh
he wasn't even human-wise as strong as
adam was sank under the weight of the
trial but uh uh um
we've got to kind of leave it there
because to go further is to go into an
area which the bible has not really uh
explained to us right and we need to
allow
uh inspired writers
to clarify later on some things that
might not have been absolutely clear
and these statements are provided here
in chronological order
uh you know the first is in
1898 the second one is in 1898.
the third one is in 1903 yes and the
final one is 1904
so she says that divinity sank she says
that divinity did not sink
but then she clarifies she says what she
meant is that divinity did not sink and
die and die in other words it did not
fully sink right
to the point
to the point that his divinity would die
so you have to kind of allow
bible writers
to in the process of time to clarify
like happened with john the baptist you
know he um
he had a process of understanding what
his mission was in fact during the time
that he was preaching he misunderstood
the kind of messiah that was going to
come virtually
he understood it when he was in prison
very true
so we need to we need to give some
leeway to
the bible writers and to the inspired
writers
to clarify and amplify the meaning of
what they said
beautifully said
think and die and of course in many many
respects ellen white grew in her
understanding of life her understanding
of her mission her understanding of
god's will uh and many of the the the
early leaders of the church we see a
progression in some of the things there
right i can look back when james white
said that the shutdown was was
functioning well you know uh
and and the question came well if the
door is shut and nobody can be saved how
come people are joining the church so he
had to revise
uh the fact that people are coming to
the lord means that the shut door is not
shut and illinois clarified at first she
believed that the door had been shut for
the world
the door of mercy was closed yes but
then in the course of time god revealed
to her that there was a shut door
those who rejected the message of
william miller leading up to 1844 who
rejected the light and attributed to it
to satan basically yes those individuals
had the door of probation closed for
them for them but it doesn't mean that
probation was closed for the world so
god clarified god clarified to ellen
white also the issue of health reform oh
yes i mean most of our pioneers were
pork eaters very much so you know and
heavy meat eaters yeah it wasn't until
that she received the health reform
vision that you know she more fully
enfleshed yes the idea of health reform
yeah and it's interesting that that that
whole health reform thing for her uh
when she came down to eat and there was
no meat on the thing she says you know
what i think i'm not hungry went back
upstairs okay now the next meal and no
meat on the table well you know maybe
i'll eat later
then she said one day i just folded my
hands over my stomach and said i will
eat this simple food or i'll eat nothing
at all so it was a process and she had
to work her way into it right yeah yeah
good point
okay let's go to our next question
um
how is it commonly claimed
especially in evangelical circles
that the jesus
that the jesus coming back to life from
the dead
was and is proof that he was god
when the bible cites by name
instance
at least 10 other people who were raised
from the dead
and yet that did not mean prove or show
that they were god
and like jesus they were
as the bible patently and copious uh
copiously um
explicitly states
raised to life ultimately by god
and as in the case of christ wouldn't
the people prophets who raised those
dead people actually be more like to be
proven to be god
if that resurrection event was such
proofing
so
basically the question is
how do we consider the resurrection of
christ to be proof of his divinity if
other individuals resurrected before
that as well were they god
that's an interesting question
we
we accept because of his own statements
that christ was god
that
divinity cannot die
and as such
uh
when he awaited the call of his father
it was
divinity calling to divinity
and
um
he didn't
need anyone to resurrect him
he was
can i say self-resurrected
um
i'm trying to i'm thinking of a text and
it's skipping my mind
john 10 17 and 18.
maybe i think you may be right
let me go there real quick you know
while you're looking for that statement
um
when jesus died on the cross the last
thing that he said was
father
into your hands i commend my spirit
why would jesus say father into your
hands i commend my spirit
it means that he was commanding his life
to the safe keeping of his father
i don't know if those are the verses
that you were thinking about indeed
there are
17 in particular
yeah
in fact why don't you just go ahead and
read those verses all right he wants 17
18 19 or 17 17 and 18. okay therefore my
father loves me because i lay down my
life
and i
that i may take it up again that's what
i was looking for okay no one takes it
from me but i lay it down of myself
i have power to lay it down and i have
power to take it again
this command i have received from my
father now that's very important the
word power here is a mistranslation
uh there is a power a word for power in
greek and it's the word dunamis where we
get the word dynamite from that's not
the word here
is exclusive
which means authority authority correct
jesus says jesus says i have authority
to lay down my life
and i have authority to take it up again
right but the question is who gave him
that authority it says at the end of
verse 18
this command i have received from my
father
so in other words the reason jesus had
the authority to lay down his life and
take it up again is because his father
had told him
that if he was faithful to him
he would call him forth from the grave
yes and then jesus would come out of the
tomb with the life that was within
himself
so in other words but if the father
hadn't called jesus authorizing him to
take back his life
jesus would not have resurrected from
the dead yes
and that's
the reason why i mentioned father into
your hands i commend my spirit yes
because he's saying to his father father
i'm i'm committing to you the safe
keeping of my life you have promised
that if i'm faithful i'm going you're
going to call me forth from the tomb yes
and i'm trusting in that so ellen white
describes it beautifully in early
writings she says that on resurrection
morning a powerful angel came and stood
before the tomb and said
son of god your father calls you yes so
you have to connect his last words on
the cross with picking up with the word
father
resurrection mourning yeah the angel as
it were served as the alarm clock but
the power to get up was there was was
resident in him uh he waited for the
callers so he's functioning within the
purview of of the divine commission and
mission sure he he got permission from
his father to act and he did act at the
correct time because his his life was
was perfect his was sinless and he had
fulfilled the requirements so he could
resurrect
because of the power that was within him
so i hope that that's helpful
the resurrection of jesus is proof i
believe of his divinity
because he says clearly here in john
chapter
i lay it down and i take it up again
notice he comes forth from the tomb with
the life that was within himself i don't
think that we could say that about moses
i don't think we could say that about
the son of the widow of nain
or jairus's daughter
or lazarus i don't think we could say
that they had life within themselves but
jesus resurrected by a life that was
within himself yes yes and you can look
at the elaborate
machinations that the person doing the
resurrection had to go through
uh
prior to their their resurrection to let
you know that the power was not in that
person it was coming from somewhere else
right through that individual to that
person that was resurrected in other
words the person the person who uh
actually was instrumental in the
resurrection was actually the channel
through which the power of god
resurrected that person the term channel
yeah
you know the next question is too
extensive so i'm going to skip that one
let's go to the next one after that
there's a question on cremation
but i think we should leave that one
because we only have just like a little
over four minutes left
so let's go to the one by peter william
if you can find that one there it has to
do with the cleansing of the sanctuary
read it for me pastor i brought out a
bunch of questions i brought out five i
was presumptuous i didn't think we would
get through uh
one two three four five i didn't think
we would get to yeah
well we have so many of them that i
decided that maybe we need to expedite
the process
so anyway this is what it says you'll
you won't have any trouble with this one
if jesus is our high priest
and he has to purify the sanctuary in
heaven
my question is
are there sins in the sanctuary
as it was in the earthly sanctuary in
other words
is there a record of sin in the heavenly
sanctuary oh yes sir it needs to be
cleansed yeah oh yes there is uh what's
happening in in in
what happened on earth in the earth a
sanctuary was a model of what happened
what uh is happening in uh the heavenly
sanctuary christ is confessing our sins
christ is is is is ministering and
that's what the book of hebrews was
written to to understand it was written
to hebrew christians who were in danger
of going back into their judaism
and beginning to try to work their way
and so what the writer of hebrews is
trying to say is there is a a jesus who
is ministering for you in the heavenly
sanctuary doing the same thing that you
saw uh in leviticus on the day of
atonement which the earthly sanctuary
and its services were a shadow precisely
that pointed to the reality so if israel
introduced their sins into the sanctuary
in the old system
that means that when we confess our sins
the sins are introduced into the
heavenly records in the heavenly
sanctuary very much so and you know we
have daniel 8 14.
i mean
it says unto 2 300 days which represents
years the sanctuary will be cleansed
well uh what sanctuary existed in 1844
there was no earthly sanctuary no no so
what is the sanctuary that was going to
be cleansed heavenly sanctuary it would
be the heavenly sanctuary yeah so is
there a record of sin up there oh yes
and some people say how can such a real
holy place have a record of sin which is
evil there
well let me ask you this how could a
perfect righteous and holy jesus bear
sin upon himself oh yes so really
the fact that there's a sin in the
heavenly sanctuary is not an issue
because god is not the author of sin
right
hebrews 9 verse 23
clearly states
that the things on earth were cleansed
by blood and the heavenly things need to
be cleansed by the blood of jesus
animals blood of animals versus blood of
jesus so let's read that verse we have
just a minute or so left
and
and i think this verse will clearly
answer
this question that has been asked
therefore
it was necessary that the copies of the
things in the heavens should be purified
with these that is with the blood of
bulls and goats yes but the heavenly
things themselves
with better sacrifices than these
for christ has not entered into holy
places made with hands which are the
copies of the true but into heaven
itself now to appear in the presence of
god for us
so clearly it says it was necessary that
the copies of the things in the heavens
should be purified yes with animal
sacrifices but the heavenly things
themselves with better sacrifices that
is the sacrifice of christ than the old
testament sacrifices so very very
clearly the bible teaches that there is
a record of sin in the heavenly
sanctuary yes that needs to be cleansed
yes
which is the burden
which comes back again and again and
again in the book of hebrews to let uh
the people know that christ is and i'll
use this modern term the real deal doing
a real work uh
that is for you and for me amen
all right oh my goodness we're at six
seconds well it's been fun for us
hopefully it's been a blessing to you
we'll see you again next time god bless
keep on reading your word bye
[Music]
you